welcome everybody to entertainment
tonight coming to you from our platform
on the gold carpet where tonight's 74th
annual emmy awards are about to go down
but we start with the somber goodbye
across the pond queen elizabeth ii
making her final journey home and then
there's the reunion that we never
thought we'd see our katie nickel has
the latest
while today was incredibly emotional for
king charles and queen console camilla
in scotland his sons and their wives
stunned crowds reuniting in windsor for
the first time in two and a half years
[Music]
[Applause]
knowing all eyes were watching check out
megan's stealth move she carefully
guides harry to switch places to stand
next to william and the feuding siblings
speak this was the first the brothers
had seen each other since their
grandmother's death it's been reported
that while harry and william were both
at balmoral they ate dinner separately
didn't interact and harry left for
windsor early the next morning so what
brought them together on saturday a text
et's learned that prince william reached
out to harry about an hour before the
moment and quote invited the duke and
duchess to join him and the princess of
wales a source tells et that the prince
of wales thought it was an important
show of unity at an incredibly difficult
time for the family
tearing up as she spoke to a fan kate
relayed how her and william's
four-year-old son reacted to the queen's
death
[Music]
there was a sense of shock and yet
incredible respect for a life
well lived hollywood is continuing to
pay tribute i love the queen and i feel
uh i feel very very very upset i've been
in a state of shock and i i wish charles
all the best as he starts to lead us in
a new direction as for the duke and
duchess of sussex we're told they plan
to remain in the uk for now there's no
word on whether archie and lilibert will
attend the queen's funeral that's been
officially set for next monday the 19th
hey it's me until then megan's
archetypes podcast has been delayed et's
learned the president and first lady
will attend the funeral at westminster
abbey where the royal family must follow
a regimented batch of protocols
including what they wear we're told that
while harry is still unable to wear his
military uniform to any event his uncle
prince andrew is allowed to be in
uniform for the final vigil only and
speaking of andrew he and ex sarah
ferguson are taking care of the queen's
beloved corgis
both will share custody of mick and
sandy at their shared royal lodge a
source close to the duke of york
explains to e.t the corgis were gifted
to her majesty by the duke the duchess
bonded with her majesty over dog walking
even after her divorce
[Music]